[Music]
Alexes in Little Rock Arkansas
hi Alex welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi Dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up well I have a question I
wanted to see what she would do in our
situation my husband is about to lose
his second job which is the only things
that's been keeping us afloat and I'm
not really educated and I can't seem to
find a job that pays him more than like
minimum wage I just don't know how we
should go about finding better paying
jobs mm-hmm okay
what is his second job his second job is
he he does the Bob truck at his work but
it's like a second job he makes like
definitely $2 an hour when he does that
okay so it's kind of like overtime at
his work yeah it's because he usually
does not dispatching there so what's he
making his main job during the day he
Mexican accent and I and he before taxes
he makes $1400 every other week and
after taxes it's like 1100 so not very
much yeah I'm the kitchen I'll go we
have to and how much dad have you got
not including your house and we have
probably twelve thousand on a cause
[Music]
twenty-seven hundred on furniture and
twelve hundred on a credit card 800 of
which was a loan to my dad that he's
supposed to be paying back so you're
broke and your husband is working
overtime to pay bills you can't afford
to pay and you loan your dad money yeah
I know
okay so we need to cut up the credit
card you'll never use it again we've got
to get you on a written budget on the
short term you know it is just finding
another extra job short term and it
could be a lot of different things the
good news is there's a lot to do in
Little Rock and then on the long term
what I would both of you do is how old
are you
we're only 21 and 23 okay so how it
asked myself what do I want to be when
I'm 41 that makes instead of making
$35,000 a year that makes $100,000 a
year okay what do I want to be what
makes me smile when I think about doing
that that pays well and that's part of
the reason I'm smiling you know
sometimes people say well living your
passion means you have to be broke no
living a passion usually means you're
not broke actually you find something
that you really are passionate about you
become a world-class at that so let's
say that you wanted to be X Y or Z when
you were 41 and he did to you sit down
talk about that tonight by the way then
you start asking yourself okay what is
keeping me from doing that and the what
you led with was you said I'm not
educated okay if you don't just
generally need to be quote-unquote
educated but you might need some
training in a particular field to be a
certain thing right young man I was
talking to earlier in the hour went and
became a a physician's assistant a PA
okay and you know that's a pretty heady
pretty academic field of study I mean
it's just right next to being a doc
right
and so he's dropped some serious brain
power into that of some serious money in
there to ruin that but it also took him
about it six or eight years to become
that and now he's making 120 hundred and
seventy a year now I'm not saying you
need to go do that but if you said
that's what I want to be then you
immediately would know I need to get
trained in that area but another example
might be that your husband says hey I'm
pretty good with computers I've always
wanted to get in technology you don't
need to get a four-year degree to make a
hundred a year to in computer world
and in the world of programming and so
forth and so he might go learn some
programming at the local tech school he
might get in some programming groups
where he's mentored he might get some of
the microsoft search certification
programs and those kinds of things we
hire lots of tech people here at six
figures and above that have zero college
but tons of tech certifications because
that proves in that world that they know
more than actually having a four-year
degree in information systems usually
so anyway the you know you'd find out
what it is you want to be and you say
what are the steps to become one of
those do I need to go take some classes
do I get in an apprenticeship program
you know I don't know maybe you know I
remember many years ago my mom who was a
high school graduate decided she want to
be in the real estate business and you
know what you have to do to be in the
real estate business passed a test
that's all now some states are now
requiring undergrad but most states you
just pass the test and then you get a
job selling real estate and you go out
there and you're the best real estate
salesperson in the world and lots of
those folks do not have four-year
degrees and so that make big money in
that world in a matter of fact so it's
just but it's what are you wired up to
do and what do you want to be someday
and the good news is you got plenty of
time to do it but let's let's aim at
something because if you aim at nothing
you're gonna be 41 and making what
you're making now okay you'll be stuck
duck is no fun and it is also no fun
being broke all the time so you got to
work part-time jobs in the mean time you
got to pay the bills right now right and
if you can get you in come back up you
can probably keep this car but otherwise
you may have to get rid of this car
because car payments killing you you
definitely got to cut up the credit
cards and you definitely got to quit
giving other people money you're
freaking broke okay you're not in a
position to do that right now I hope
someday that you've lived like no one
else and then you're able to live and
give like no one else but no more of
that the more that misbehavior and so
your husband apparently has a CDL
commercial driver's license so maybe he
can drive something else maybe he could
get on with somebody else at night or
during the day or maybe there's some
dump trucks that need to be driven
there's a lot of a lot of construction
around Little Rock right now I don't
know I'm just making this up as I go but
you need some part-time income and you
need a long-term goal and start taking
the steps towards that long-term goal
hold on I'm going to send you a copy of
a book called start that will help you
with that process